who do you think is the brains honestly
jeffrey and she's lying yeah
neither well here's what i mean by that
jazlane's father was intelligence
jaslane was very schooled in the world
of intelligence right and you know
understanding like what intelligence is
is the maintenance of relationships yeah
essentially right and having leverage
over people and how relationships are
structured and
who has the upper hand at any given time
and that could change and blah blah blah
and you know so just lane understood
that her dad was this media mogul robert
maxwell who's murdered um her sisters
are in tech
it's an intelligence family um
epstein was a you know kind of
you know from many people that have met
him
sort of
by no means brilliant guy right like he
was not this
amazing intellect however he had a
very good understanding of
people
their their
appetites their proclivities their
weaknesses
um surrounding underage women
surrounding
illicit streams of money where they
wanted their money hidden um i'm sure
surrounding many other things as well he
was he seemed to be very good at that i
think
the way that they both functioned
was a team
of people that
you know ran this very i think epstein
was the public face
of it as a philanthropist
as an investor
um i think just lane was just a
socialite but
uh not just a socialite you know to the
public just to socialize but
behind the scenes she was a madam she
was a pimp she was an access agent she
connected uh jeffrey to people that were
very powerful in the uk and and other
places that were friends of her father
um and they they had an operation that
was based on
entrapping blackmailing gaining leverage
over
very powerful
politicians so do you think there was an
intelligence connection to all of this
mossad it was absolutely a messiah here
was
with eric on this oh it was a mossad
operation but that doesn't mean the cia
didn't know about it and give it its
blessing you know the cia ran operations
like this in the 80s
in the 90s uh these honeypot blackmail
operations are not terribly new they
were pioneered by the mafia i mean this
has been going back for
a very long time you know but like have
so many powerful people involved rich
people oh yeah sure i mean that's the
point
the point is to
all of these institutions whether it's
council on foreign relations or all
these things where people think are very
like nefarious whatever it is bohemian
grove or skull and bones all these
things where they really are they just
create
a consensus amongst the wealthiest and
most powerful people on the planet and
that consensus becomes our foreign
policy our domestic policy our corporate
policy
so it's just creating a consensus so if
you put a bunch of young guys at yale
together and whatever they do whatever
bonding activities they do to become
closer
uh or if you put them out in the woods
in monterey california at bohemian grove
or if you put them on an island
committing crimes
what this does is this fosters a sense
of
um you know mutually assured destruction
uh a sense of um
you know
how
homogeneous
you know ruling a homogeneous ruling
class i i agree by the way i should
mention for the record ben is wearing a
harvard shirt yeah that he was given to
by a fat woman who's no longer fat
because she had a gastric bypass
if you were more fat forward yes like
your friend you wouldn't even make that
comment but i mean i think i'm right
about this where it's like it's an
intelligence op
they were the face of it as they moved
into the digital world it became less
necessary to have these physical
honeypots yeah you tweeted about this
that the the the true tragedy of giselle
maxwell is that
it's just yet another human being losing
out to automation it's they're being
replaced by ai no matter what you think
of jeffrey anders elaine is a real issue
human trafficking used to involve humans
yeah there's a human cost
this is absolutely the case
do you think i'm wrong about anything
i've said
well
i'm uncomfortable with the intelligent
connection you know why
uh
so there's a book about slain's father
called israel super spy yeah so the
father is definitely shady okay so the
father's in the mossad we no i don't
know about the mossad thing you don't
know about that there's something about
the suicide or whatever the death yeah
but it's kind of widely
uh believed you know he was at the
funeral and i forgot if this big is
really premier like i think he's wide
but there's a difference between for
example if i have a conversation with
putin am i part of the fsb no but that's
an important you know elon musk was once
at a party which is laying maxwell at
the same party and she's everybody was
at a party with jesus maxwell well yes
and so the question is what is the depth
of the connection
well it's it's there's book there's a
book about it i mean it's it's i have a
lot of books about a lot of stuff to
show well but written by seymour hirsch
i mean ben get the title of the book up
right get to what is the title of the
book written by one of america's
greatest pulitzer prize winning
journalist
okay
yeah but also seymour hirsch wrote
something it might not have been a book
but seymour hirsch wrote something as
well
about
about him but but again it's there's an
entire book about it so there is
evidence no i know so um
i'm under informed about this topic i
just have a general
wariness of calling people intelligence
yeah so because it's such a tempting
like whenever i in my
mind
feel a temptation
uh to see a conspiracy theory in
something i i i uh has so what do you
think it would be if it wasn't
intelligence what and let's say it's not
the mossad we'll back that out yeah
which it was but it's also cia and the
mossad and saudi intelligence are all
like really tight and mi6 they're like
bros yeah so
and then there's like iranian
intelligence
and
russian intelligence and syrian
intelligence and they're like cool
they're like friends yeah so this is a
view of the world right with the
intelligence organizations is ultra
competent
i yes they are okay well this is my my
view
is they're not ultra complex not all of
them they're exceptionally well funded
they're large organizations that have a
lot of people pushing paper and they are
pretty effective a lot of things but
there's these are not the a students of
the world i believe okay let's the a
students don't run the world c students
do
you don't have to be an a student if
you're willing to kill someone
truly if you're a c student and you're
willing to put a gun in someone's mouth
yes it's actually probably
just as good as having an a
what would you say it if it's not an
intelligence blackmail operation what
would you
uh say that it could be
i would say it's
one charismatic person
jeffrey epstein yeah
that was
evil and committed things
um but that's a great everyone listening
to this is you sound crazy on this show
which is why i enjoy doing it
no not everybody i'm not i'm a little
bit playing devil's advocate here so i'm
not don't fully believe this but there's
a there's a sense
where i feel that
there's an important distinction to draw
jeffrey epstein being a complete
manufacturing manifestation of an
intelligence agency versus as one
charismatic evil person becomes more and
more successful individualist
on an individual level you start meeting
powerful people and then intelligence
does
things
necessarily the entire intelligence
agency right the these these
intelligence agencies are bureaucracies
but they do have within them
fiefdoms and factions of power you have
bad actors you have people that are
outside of the agency officially
that have all the skills and know all
the people
so it's not necessarily as easy as going
like it's the entire cia behind any of
these things right but there are groups
of people all the intelligence agencies
do is they work for billionaires
essentially they work for american
corporate interests that's what the cia
does they've overthrown governments at
the behest of american corporate
interests this is the cia works for
wealthy people they essentially are the
information the muscle
and yes
where we cannot do things overtly uh
with our military
uh and with u.s policy
and get things passed through congress
you have a shadow organization that's
able to do that that's not terribly
controversial right i mean that's pretty
well known if you look at all the coups
you know in other countries that are
provable coups may be in this country
that are
what's what's important for me to
understand what this is i don't think
it's controversial the question is the
scale
at which how many people are involved
how much
uh
like how much of it is at the core what
the cia does versus this is a few people
well the core of what the cia does
probably is largely
you know they gather a lot of
information and analyze it yeah but then
they're like the core of any business
right so if you looked at walmart the
core of walmart is you going in and
buying socks and someone taking your
money you know but then there's a group
of people
in walmart
making decisions and charting the
direction of the company and what
they're gonna do for the next five or
ten years so i think the core of these
institutions can be relatively benign
but the there's again power factions
within them that are not all homogenous
right there's people in the cia that had
no idea what was going on there's people
that would be disgusted by it there's
people that would be repulsed by it
there's no getting around this fact
blackmail has been
uh an essential part of the recruitment
of
agents
it's been an essential part of
maintaining relationships with people
this is how
intelligence people have often found
leverage to gain information yeah that
is true yeah that's very true the my
question is how
is that increasing or decreasing the
amount of that being done so ultimately
my question is about so whenever you
think intelligence
is running
the most powerful people in the world
they're blackmailed and everything is
being controlled by by certain very
powerful figures you you
very naturally
lead to a cynicism about the future of
the world that deeply troubles me so
like i want to land an optimism like
with with people have you tried drugs
uh no drugs
not all of them drugs are very good for
this
because they have mechanism well they
make you feel a way that reality might
not no i don't think so i think drugs
i'm not saying everything's cynical i'm
not saying everybody's controlled what i
am saying is that
one cannot bury their head in the sand
when there is a
island
and a mansion in new york city that has
recording equipment you have a guy that
was let off the first time with a very
sweetheart deal who's paddling around
with prime ministers kings and president
it's the definition of this looks bad
but i would argue as the nature gaze
into the abyss and hibiscuses back into
you i would argue if all you study is
the jeffrey epstein case yeah you will
see devils everywhere you i don't think
there's devils everywhere so this is the
burden
of the great that's the cunan was that's
also i mean
jones talks about this alex is crazy
i love alex but he's nuts when you
constantly analyze this stuff you just
it's that's all you see is red
understood and so if you don't see any
red that's also a problem if there's no
devils you go well i don't think there's
any devils the that's an issue there's
definitely a balance strike there i
i it seems unsupported
that this is one evil person and another
evil person together
with no larger no no the the the network
builds over time right and they
a lot of it is parties and handshakes
and so on and you greet each other
politicians
i'm sure so okay one one thing
that seems to be the case
because i've known people that interact
with jeffrey epstein
he seems he completely deluded them like
the charisma is there and it doesn't
have to do with money
or
uh women
at the core level it has to do with
straight up in the room
together yeah and so
i just believe that one charismatic guy
can do a lot of damage in this world
without first um
sort of uh being manufactured as a
strategic deployment onto the united
states by some intelligence agency now
over time as he interacts with more and
more powerful people he probably met he
probably got some phone calls and
probably had some meetings i don't even
think i would say that he was deployed i
think that
i don't believe
that the way these agencies necessarily
operate is that we're thinking of them
as
you know custodians of national interest
which i don't think they are right i
think they are kind of
work for hire organizations where
there's certain people in those
countries that have a lot of money that
have an idea about the way things should
be run that you know kind of use these
agencies i don't necessarily think that
like
all of these agencies all the time
are focused on
um the betterment of any one particular
nation state i think there's a certain
group of people
that have enough money and enough power
that use these agencies as ways to
sustain that
uh position in society so i think
epstein whether it was in tel aviv or in
london or in manhattan was having
conversations with these people whose
loyalty is really not to
any particular country but it's to their
own interests i just have to say that i
am really troubled
on a personal level yeah that there's a
lot of people i respect
that when they were in a room with
jeffrey epstein were not able to see the
we're not able to see evil would not
have the integrity no because they were
looking at [ __ ] well this is this is
the this is the the thing is i mean
maybe i'm build different this is isn't
that like a ford thing or something uh
built yeah uh
it's chevy
[Laughter]
i i just think you can't let [ __ ] or
money delude you and and destroy your
integrity integrity should be above all
else and when i see
that not being the case with jeffrey
epstein um like people that have spoken
with jeff epstein that really troubles
me
that
his
charisma
and manipulation revealed the people who
lack integrity in my view now i could be
naive
because you could be the next jeffrey
epstein and ben could be the next
chisely maxwell and here i am
doing this beautiful podcast and i'm
even a fan so maybe it's your charisma
though nobody's giving me um uh an
island nobody's giving me an island and
nobody's giving me the largest uh one of
the largest uh pieces of real estate in
manhattan this is also the problem when
you look at this
um you know as uh just this independent
uh thing uh you look at well why did les
wexner was the head of the limited
brands gift
jeffrey epstein these
massive
insanely desirable pieces of real estate
uh it's one in new york city right
um
what is the connection there that's that
that connection has not been proven yeah
yeah that one yeah what people have
spoken about that's really shady i mean
that's just a shady connection right so
you have this guy
who is a well-established human
trafficker
and you have his biggest benefactor
uh financially not questioned at all in
any meaningful way
about this
i mean you can be as as averse to
conspiracy theories as you want
but a lot of times unfortunately they
just become the news
and this has kind of become the news
yeah yeah it's become the news but i
understand your thing i think your
thing's valid
the q and on movement which is psychotic
people whose minds had melted
when they got a few nuggets of truth and
then they concocted
disney-esque
childish stories
about good and evil because they wanted
everything in life to have
the clarity
and certitude of religion and they
created this thing where everyone in
hollywood's evil and everyone's a
pedophile and then dead people are going
to come back and jfk junior was it was a
very religious movement
that's what happens to people when they
see devils everywhere and they're unable
to
uh differentiate fact from fiction and
then on the other side there's similar
things in the the scientific community
has really been disappointing to me
about the level of arrogance how they
dismiss every conspiracy they just
dismiss basically everything is a
conspiracy theory that's not
like
very narrowly defined uh public policy i
watched your interview with the ceo of
pfizer that guy the greek guy who owns a
diner
and what i like about
that interview
was that he was a um
[Laughter]
no but he's
offended the greeks the italians
who don't even though he's the ceo of
pfizer he literally owns a diner in a
story of queens where he brings out
hispanic carpet and yells at his his
wife and their nephews who work at the
diner yeah by the way that's the reality
i'm guessing his son is a fan of yours
because uh his son mentioned the podcast
he likes he's a fan of this podcast or
my podcast and i'm guessing they're a
fan of me i mean very smart people
listen to you that doesn't mean they
come over to me yeah they should that's
the this
yeah that's the the next step but my
answer to him is less listening to lex
friedman and more getting people
mozzarella sticks in your father's day
to get back to work because when i see
that guy you go oh he's a ceo of fives i
go this is a guy who owns a diner yeah
and it's a struggling diner
but it's good they get they make they
make good they get mileage out of the
coleslaw let me finish up with this ben
how long have we done we've done a while
can i just say yes before you finish up
yes
how much i love ben he's really
the best part of your podcast and is a
that's not true but ben is uh no i love
ben ben is essential for me to do what i
do and he's just a kind soul he's a
console he's a good hearted person he's
a good-hearted person and he works very
very hard
and
he's one of these people where i'm lucky
to have a ben not everybody has a band
right
so i'm lucky to have him now that being
said
he must be watched
very closely harvard he must be oh you
know who else wore a harvard sweatshirt
jeffrey epstein yeah is that the is that
the reason yeah
yeah but ben must be watched like
everyone they must be surveilled yeah